bonjour bon alors c'est aujourd'hui que
le conseil d'état va trancher sur la
question
levée des rassemblements de plus de 10
personnes trois avocates ont été lancées
par des ong et des syndicats dont la cgt
la fsu le syndicat de la magistrature ou
encore le syndicat des avocats le
conseil d'état va donc devoir concilier
respect de manifester et la protection
est de la santé puisque plusieurs
mesures et dispositions ou été prise
pendant l'état d'urgence sanitaire
cette demande elle intervient à un
moment assez particulier puisque vous
savez elle ces derniers jours ont été
ponctuée par plusieurs rassemblements de
plusieurs manifestations qui étaient
censés être interdite en mémoire à
georges floyd ou encore adama traoré
pour dénoncer le racisme les violences
policières
selon la ldh ces dispositions réduisait
les liberté de manifester alors si cette
demande est refusée par le conseil
d'état elle les manifestants ne pourront
manifester qu'après le 10 juillet car
c'est la date qui marque la fin de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
mona merci pour toutes ces précisions